strom gewinnen und das ohne schädliche
abgase oder chemikalien check egal zu
welcher tageszeit und dabei völlig
wetterunabhängig check quasi
unerschöpfliche ressource
das ist nicht ein wirrer tag traum von
mir sondern tatsächlich der steckbrief
einer vielleicht unterschätzen methode
der stromgewinnung ich rede von osmose
kraftwerken die sich den
unterschiedlichen salzgehalt von wasser
zu nutze machen
wie genau das funktioniert und ob dieses
konzept demnächst für eine revolution
bei der stromerzeugung sorgen wird jetzt
in klick zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen 70 prozent der erdoberfläche
sind mit wasser bedeckt die idee das
wasser in mehreren flüssen und seen zu
nutzen um damit strom zu erzeugen ist
also mehr als sinnvoll
neben wasserkraftwerken und staudämmen
beispielsweise gibt es eine weitere
möglichkeit osmose-kraftwerk nämlich
schon in den 70er jahren gab es erste
vorschläge dazu sich den
unterschiedlichen salzgehalt des wassers
zu nutze zu machen in den 90er jahren
gab es erste konkrete forschungsprojekte
und im jahr 2009 hat norwegen dann den
ersten prototypen in betrieb genommen
bei dieser art der stromerzeugung spielt
die unterschiedliche salzkonzentration
von meer und süßwasser eine
entscheidende rolle konkret funktioniert
das so eine semi per mail an lieb links
wort von mir also eine halb
durchlässige membran trend salz und
süßwasser voneinander beide
flüssigkeiten streben einen
druckausgleich an wodurch ein druck auf
die membran ausgeführt dadurch wird
eine turbine in gang gesetzt sie
unterschiedlicher der salzgehalt der
gewässer ist und je höher die
durchflussmenge ist desto höher ist der
energiegewinnung also osmose kraftwerke
zu betreiben braucht es standorte wo
süß und salzwasser aufeinandertreffen
flussmündung wie die der elbe
beispielsweise ihre vorteile sind enorm
osmose kraftwerk sind wetterunabhängig
ganz im gegensatz zu windkraft sie
können rund um die uhr betrieben werden
da sich der wasser zustrom beliebig
regeln lässt und außerdem sind
osmose-kraftwerk emissionsfrei und
setzen auch sonst keinerlei giftige
chemikalien frei ein weiterer pluspunkt
im gegensatz zur windkrafträdern
beispielsweise ließen sich
osmose-kraftwerk relativ unauffällig
in die umwelt integrieren etwa durch den
bau in deichen außerdem und das ist ein
wirklich entscheidender faktor ist diese
methode der stromgewinnung praktisch
unerschöpflich und doch der prototyp
der 2009 in norwegen in betrieb genommen
wurde und eine leistung von 4 kilowatt
produzierte hielt sich gerade einmal
vier jahre lang und das obwohl die
anlage gut funktionierte und der
betreiber bereits eine zweite anlage mit
einer höheren leistung geplant hatte
doch dann wurde der prototyp ende 2013
überraschender weise ausgeschaltet das
unternehmen begründete dies so eine
weiterentwicklung der technologie zu
einem konkurrenzfähigen status sei bei
den derzeitigen marktaussichten einfach
nicht möglich gemeint waren damit wohl
die günstigen preise für gas kohle und
öl die alternativen konzepten keine
chancen lassen zudem hatte norwegen
beschlossen dass es anders als bei
windkraft keine einspeisevergütung
geben sollte
ein trauriges beispiel hätte man damit
doch gegebenenfalls zeigen können dass
osmose strom machbar ist und sinnvoll
dazu es gibt studien die schätzen dass
13 prozent des weltweiten
energieverbrauchs durch osmose
kraftwerke abgedeckt werden könnten
doch dazu müssten alle geeigneten
flussmündungen mit diesem system
ausgestattet werden ja sagen wir mal
realistisch praktisch ist das wohl nicht
umsetzbar andere studien gehen deshalb
wohl auch eher von drei prozent aus eine
weitere methode den unterschiedlichen
salzgehalt von wasser ausnutzt wurde
bereits in den niederlanden getestet und
zwar an dem deich der die nordsee vom
ijsselmeer trend dieses konzept
funktioniert ähnlich wie eine batterie
nämlich mit zwei arten von membranen
vergleichbar also mit dem bagger beiden
batterie polen der unterschiedliche
salzgehalt von salz und süßwasser
lässt die ionen durch diese membranen
man dadurch entsteht zwischen den
membran eine elektrische spannung
elektrizität also doch auch diese idee
ist wirtschaftlich nicht wirklich
tragfähig zu wenig strom wird
produziert um in günstig zu verkaufen
bei einigen monaten publizierten us
forschungsteam eine idee um dieses
problem anzugehen gleich zwei chemische
verfahren werden bei dieser methode
benutzt um energie zu werden zum einen
wie auch bei den herkömmlichen
konzepten an der membran zwischen den
wassermassen vom anwalt
so schlagen die forscherinnen und
forscher vor könne gleichzeitig aber
auch energie an den elektroden im wasser
gewonnen werden denn sobald die wasser
mit unterschiedlichem salzgehalt
ausgesetzt sind wird eine spannung
erzeugt diese kombination zweier
methoden würde mehr energie und weniger
kosten bedeuten 40 prozent des
weltweiten stromverbrauchs könnten so
gedeckt werden so das forschungsteam
gleichzeitig aber auch direkt die
einschränkung dass diese technologie
noch weit entfernt von erster pilot
anlagen sei das größte problem dabei
die hohen kosten der ionenaustausch
membran eine weitere idee die
forscherteams weltweit verfolgen ist
abwässer aus entsalzungsanlagen zu
nutzen
der vorteil hier eine noch höhere
salzkonzentration als reines mehr wasser
mit sich bringt auch hier erhofft man
sich die effektivität der osmose
technik in zukunft deutlich zu
verbessern zudem würde man hierbei zwei
fliegen mit einer klappe schlagen denn
die abwässer aus trinkwassergewinnung
sind so salzig dass man sie nicht in die
umwelt entsorgen darf das fazit also an
dieser stelle viel forschungsarbeit ist
noch nötig wenn man aus mose kraftwerk
wirklich wettbewerbsfähig machen will
forschungsarbeit die sich aber
tatsächlich lohnen könnte denn die
vision von der osmose kraft als
wichtiger bestandteil der
energieerzeugung hat viel reiz und wäre
fast zu schön um wahr zu sein doch bis
uns die revolution bei der
stromerzeugung kurz bevorsteht sind bei
allen methoden noch probleme zu lösen
und das nicht zu knapp aber methoden zur
regenerativen energieerzeugung gibt es
eine menge zuletzt haben wir ja erst die
methode zur wasserstoff gewinnung aus
licht und wasser durch photosynthese
vorgestellt ja wenn er zu diesem thema
zu allen anderen themen nicht verpassen
wollte dadurch mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den genau auf
die glocke hier geht es übrigens zum
thema revolutionärer treibstoff wasser
wo es eben um die wasserstoff gewinnung
mittels photosynthese geht das ist
wirklich sensationell unbedingt ansehen
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran